tout le monde est prêt vous êtes prêts
on y va quand même on y va quand même ce
sont des sportives et elles ont posté
ceci c'est c'est
hyper heureux de vous avoir ce soir
c'est vrai qu'on se disait avec
Christophe cet été non vous vous êtes
pas très heureux moi je suis très
heureuse
Christophe
donc c'est là où on peut voir des coups
qui sont un peu mais
qui arrive aussi
voilà alors ce qui a fait beaucoup
parler c'est le duo de chaman et elle
est à Salamé alors est-ce qu'il y a duré
fifiée entre les deux est-ce que c'était
fluide qu'en pensez-vous alors moi je
voulais juste mettre un petit peu
d'une grande objectivité est plutôt par
les chiffres puisque là il me semble que
c'est 13 % de de part d'audience quand
c'était 17 pour la première sachant que
pour la seconde à nouveau il y avait
très peu de concurrence en face la
semaine qui arrive beaucoup plus
compliqué comment oui une perte de 4
points c'est quand même beaucoup
malheureusement et cette semaine il y a
la Star Ac qui arrive si je ne me trompe
pas donc bon en tout cas très vite la
star acade arrive donc ça risque d'être
encore plus compliqué sachant que pour
la première il y a quand même eu trois
heures qui ont été coupées donc ce qui
veut bien dire que c'était pas très
fluide et je peux me permettre et autre
élément de comparaison 100% logique le
prime juste avant quelle époque était
beaucoup plus puissant cette semaine que
la semaine passée donc moins de report
moindre donc pour vous c'est alarmant
par rapport à leur relation tous les
deux Christophe et il est assalamé on
avait dit ici que l'école possible c'est
que Christophe Dechavanne sorte de sa
zone de chroniqueur et deviennent un peu
co-animateur et là dans la deuxième
émission je trouve que c'était très
visible il a voulu interrompre beaucoup
rachidady la voulu exister et à un
moment dans ses yeux elle à sa manière
de lui parler dans les yeux de Léa
Salamé j'ai vraiment discerné que ça
commençait un peu à l'énerver voilà
est-ce que vous pensez que je suis
d'accord
est-ce que dechavan pourra garder ce
rôle de numéro 2 à votre avis
moi je pense que si il veut garder sa
place il a tout intérêt à garder son
rôle de numéro 2 parce que pour le
moment on lui propose on lui propose pas
de numéro 1 donc dans tous les cas après
moi ce qui concerne le duo ça me fait
pas peur spécialement parce que vous
avez encore mieux que moi à quel point
c'est compliqué de s'installer à la télé
et dans un rôle particulier donc la
première c'est très bien passé parce que
c'était un peu plus polis c'est un peu
plus lisse etc là c'est la deuxième ils
ont tous les deux pris un peu leur
marque ils sont en train de se tester un
petit peu et je pense que c'est tout à
l'heure intérêt après de faire en sorte
que ça se passe bien donc moi j'ai pas
peur pour la suite
Dechavanne c'est un animateur de
télévision et que c'est un numéro à la
base c'est un numéro 1 et de passer
chroniqueur c'est toujours autre chose
c'est un autre métier d'être chroniqueur
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'animation et
ça c'est clair et d'ailleurs je me rends
pas compte
pas trop ce terme non plus non pas trop
ce terme non plus hein sauf que tout est
dit parce que quand il est venu ici il a
dit je ne suis pas chroniqueur je suis
invité permanent
sauf que sauf que sauf que dans
l'émission il avait des interventions
qui étaient quand même celle d'un
chroniqueur il parlait de politique il a
fait une comparaison avec l'Italie il a
pas l'Italie du fascisme il y avait un
rôle d'intervenant chroniqueur oui pas
d'animateur invité c'est mieux que c'est
mieux chroniqueurs
le tout petit problème c'est parce que
lui il a aussi le rôle de sniper ce qui
est un appel aussi invité permanent et
c'est vrai que là on est aussi entre
plusieurs rôles en revanche qui était
très drôle c'est Rachida Dati et le mec
qui apparaît alors moi d'abord les trucs
positifs cave rivière alors qu'à rivière
pardon mais moi je considère que c'est
c'était une révélation là c'est
clairement une démonstration je trouve
qu'il est incroyable ensuite c'est faire
peu de cas de l'intelligence de Léa
Salamé qui malgré tout doit sentir son
plateau sans les dangers et va bien
comprendre comment elle doit manager
Christophe Dechavanne mais il y a eu un
truc qui était très évident quand ils
sont venus ici c'est quand même elle la
star du programme elle était pas au
milieu c'était deux Chavannes qui
étaient au milieu elle elle était en
bout de table elle était presque dehors
de la star en dehors de la table donc
oui il prend de la place il prend du
pouvoir effectivement l'interview de
Rachida Dati moi en tant que
téléspectatrice estime que il me l'a
volé parce qu'il a instauré un truc un
peu de complicité de minauderie de
cabotinage on se dragoût et on se fait
des blagues et tout et du coup je trouve
qu'en fait il a volé la séquence vous
dites en fait il est pas légitime dans
ce rôle là en tout cas pas là je trouve
que du coup il a tué l'interview
politique parce que avec Mélenchon elle
avait été exceptionnel et lui avec
Mélenchon avait été exceptionnel sauf
que là il a il a il a basculé dans autre
chose mais je pense que là ça la met va
tout de suite redresser le petit
festivalent pour le rebond qu'elle ça a
été un festival de Rachida Dati qui est
très très bonne regardez très comprendre
pourquoi on les Italiens on arrive là
donc ça c'est le premier mais c'est pas
que le passé il y a le présent il y a
beaucoup de personnes le passé le passé
non mais c'est un peu je vous ai vu la
semaine dernière pareil je finis la
phrase puis après on discute si vous
voulez parce que franchement c'est un
peu
je vous présente Rachida datina non mais
c'est un peu énervant quoi
je te jure que j'ai participé alors ça
c'est votre problème mais vous
intéressez pas ma vie tout va bien voilà
ok simplement non il n'y a pas espérer
je reste à la mienne
on arrive on arrive sur la mairie de
Paris
moi je pense qu'il faudrait le sortir je
l'aime beaucoup Christophe Dechavanne il
faudrait le sortir totalement de
l'interview politique c'est pas son truc
il interrompt on sait pas très bien dans
quel univers on est excellent
je trouve que ça dessert l'émission les
interruptions
change de rôle ou on a envie de dire il
est pas légitime
il était franchement hyper bien critiqué
les retours étaient hyper positifs on
critique sur la deuxième émission
pourquoi parce que c'est interview
politique de Rachida Dati elle a été
constamment interrompue à la pas pu
répondre il en sort rien là on tombe un
peu dans la course à la séquence et
c'est un peu dommageable de tomber dans
ça
moi Laurent Ruquier me manque pardon
mais voilà sa folie me manque il y a
quelque chose qu'il avait il combinait
en fait les deux et là et ça dissocier
en fait deux choses qui fonctionnent pas
très bien ensemble et pour moi
ça fonctionne correctement pour
l'instant alors est-ce que s'ils étaient
en direct ce serait mieux meilleur et
bien non
vous oubliez un personnage c'est le
producteur parce que pardon si ça n'a
pas changé Léa elle a le producteur à
l'oreillette donc je suis désolé mais en
rebond le Chavan n'est plus naturel et
spontané qu'elle parce qu'il y a
toujours un intermédiaire donc donc moi
je il y a des rôles la définir ça veut
dire que je pense que elle a souvent des
consignes par l'oreillette alors que de
Chavanne il est un électron libre donc
effectivement il y a un rôle à trouver
mais je suis pas sûr du tout
c'est vrai que c'est connu qu'elle a un
côté plus journalistique et qu'elle
bosse plus à l'oreillette que par
exemple comme tu en parlais Laurent qui
faisait les choses de façon un peu plus
spontanée et à l'instinct donc
finalement son rôle devrait être quand
même important puisqu'il apporterait ce
grain de folie qui justement manque à
Léa ça ne prend pas
et ça fait ça fait de gaieté
que ça va être durer non carrément non
moi je pense pas
à ce chiffre là je vous le savez ça peut
durer 10 ans bien sûr je pense que ça
risque de baisser ils auront pas ils
auront pas des interlocuteurs politiques
Mélenchon Rachida Dati de ce niveau-là
tout le temps c'est très dur à trouver
voilà puis la concurrence il faut
prendre en compte la concurrence donc ça
va durer mais ça devrait baisser
ça va durer ça devrait baisser en tout
cas
il s'en foutent parce que c'est notre
argent de toute façon
c'est vrai à cette heure-ci il y a plus
de pub bah oui
ils vont bientôt se prendre la Coupe du
monde dans la gueule en plus il dure un
avec trois matchs par jour ça joue à 23h
ce soir
bon les amis on va suivre évidemment si
cette affaire